i got one question samuel this is it
sammy if if the audience is watching
uh uh our outcome was the way you know
our outcome was to
you know a lot of people ask me and they
say so pat what do you think this has
led to with all these conversations i
said number one
uh you know
if you look at the lifestyle on what's
happened you know both michael and sami
they're no longer part of the life both
of them are on businesses michael runs
successful businesses sammy's
doing very well for himself as well
which means
this was a way out this this worked out
creating content telling stories etc etc
and you've gone to a different life now
your grandparents parents it's a
different phase you're no longer 20s 30s
when you're in the hunt you want to go
there that's a completely different life
you're living right now and there there
is a sincere feel of you wanting to make
a transition into the next life but
sammy the question i have is
some of the audience that's listening to
this right now they see the frustration
between the two of you they still don't
know what was
what was so michael made a comment about
your name being there he says sammy
drops your name 11 seconds he cuts it
what part of that reference upsets you
though what was that because i don't
think fully the audience knows what
frustrated you with that comment if you
don't mind elaborating that if you're
comfortable with that
when you make [ __ ] statements about
people
about their cooperation
and why they shouldn't get out of prison
and you make statements that the proof
is in the pudding when they get out they
lie to the government
they turn around and they recommit
crimes and he mentions a couple of
people including my name in that group
my name didn't have to be in that group
he could if that was his feelings he
could have just said that
he didn't have to put my [ __ ] name in
the thing
that's number one number two
when he he cooperated and did certain
things it was all right for him to
cooperate against naby walters whether
he went to prison or not he got
convicted under michael's testimony he
got a 395 000 fine he got sentenced to
prison and the case was overturned
because the judge made a mistake on the
case
something that affected the law end of
it not michael ordered his testimony or
nothing and the case was reversed
he comes out of [ __ ] prison
there was there's interviews people
wanted to talk to me they don't even
want to talk about michael frantis or
his father he hates them
so and this guy here was a family friend
of this
family friend they shook him down for
money and then ratted on him
and that's supposed to be okay so you
could do that but somebody else who has
a problem in them if they were betrayed
or whatever their story is
you that you're gonna be the high
priestess who tells them you're no good
you shouldn't get out when he was able
to get out he had a 10-year sentence
a 10-year sentence that was reduced to
three years of four months
for his [ __ ] testimony you you were
there when we talked about his 15
million dollar fine
he never paid it
he says well i paid ribs and drebs but i
never paid at all
you can walk away from the [ __ ]
government and say i'm not paying it
that don't work that was probably done
because he cooperated whatever his fine
was they probably niched it
whatever they did
i can't prove that i can't say that but
those things don't just disappear
they're there
so without cooperation you ain't getting
these things from the government there's
millions of people who went to prison
you can't get squat
from the government when you're
convicted
nothing
whether it's a fine whether it's the
time
reductions you've got to do something to
get reactions
and there's there's tapes there's agents
saying yeah the argument the the new
york prosecutors were arguing with the
chicago prosecutors they wanted him to
cooperate against
carmine persico
he wouldn't do it or whatever that is i
i don't doubt maybe he didn't want to do
it
and he didn't
but the chicago people won out they used
them there and he got his favors he
cooperated now
he didn't have murders he don't he never
murdered anybody in his life from what i
understand
that's but he'll say i don't have cover
for that
so i can't talk about it it's another
innuendo
of making the people whose people think
well he did what he had to do to get
into life and you don't want to talk
about it why don't you just be truthful
and say i never killed anybody
your followers probably a lot of them
who are christians would say that's good
he never killed anybody
but he just can't it can't seem to tell
the truth when it comes to these things
i don't know why
i really don't
so that's why and that's why he had a
lot of guys on the street who he says
they're nobodies
and uh and he knows who they are i don't
want to mention their names because i
don't want to start a [ __ ] revolution
here but they they just badmouth them
all the time until i got into the
picture how could you do anything he
tells me i got into the people into the
picture tonight i shut them all up
michael ain't a bad guy leave him alone
he lied so he lied that's none of your
business
leave it alone
john gotti jr
is not my [ __ ] friend
he's gonna do this thing
uh my uh wet sack mafia and he's gonna
bear mouth people now i'm gonna give you
and your whole audience and michael
guess who the [ __ ] he's gonna hurt the
most he'll come after the most it'd
probably be me and he's congratulating
him on his project
and and there's a guy another made guy
riding on everybody and his mother
which is insane
and i don't know why you would talk good
about him
he met with the government he's done a
[ __ ] gazillion [ __ ] things
that it's it's a complete joke so now
when he did that video
and the thing that bothered me the most
was
that him and his wife and kids are in
church and they're praying for me
he had a catastrophe have it
a week or two before
with a young boy it's not his fault
he could pray for him
why do you want to pray for me i'm not
sick i'm not dead i'm not in jail why
would you want to pray for me
so i took that little prayer you sent me
as
he's trying to soften me up from this
video
he knew i would explode at that video
because we're supposed to at this point
be getting along
then you put out this video you tap him
on the back let me get back to john
gotti's doing it him himself he's
sitting in
health magazine health health men's
health magazine
stating that he is a crime fighter now
he wants to put people in prison
he wants to do stories about people who
should have never got out of prison
how hypocritical is this
and he wants to say oh he's doing a
great job
this is your father who did 50 years
and it's a cooperative but this is the
guy who wants to put people in prison he
says it he admits it
publicly it's in magazines
so i got to sit here and listen to this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
after trying my best to do the right
thing
with this show
and have a relationship with him and put
things in the past
a couple of days goes by and there's
this [ __ ] video and i get 40 50
[ __ ] people calling me
i said i don't know why he did it
and i'm sitting there like a jackass
over and over again
well i don't know
i ain't a bad guy he i don't know why he
did it i don't even know what the [ __ ]
to say
to people
and then this
emergency meeting comes up with me and
michael i don't want to hurt the project
i don't want to hurt nothing i didn't
want to be here you know it
but i said i'll i'll be here
and then we exploded just now at each
other i don't know what it does to the
project i hope it don't hurt it i i
don't know what it does
and i don't really care
not it's
not
can i respond to this please sure go
forward yeah can i respond to this first
of all
first of all i don't know who these 40
or 50 people are at number one number
two
number two
again i didn't say anything positive
about j sammy says i do innuendos he
makes things up i didn't say anything
positive about john gotti i mentioned a
public fact that john gotti is coming
out with something called the whitsect
mafia i told sammy this i never met john
gotti i never spoke to john gotti jr
talking about junior i have no
relationship with him whatsoever i've
never communicated with him other than
one time with his lawyer 10 12 years ago
that was it
that's number one so i don't even know
what he's upset about with that i have
no relationship and i told sammy that
and that's the godzilla he was told you
said he's doing a great job let me
finish i didn't say he's doing a great
job let me finish okay that's number one
when it comes to norby walters sammy
seems to claim to know everything about
everything norby walters here's the
facts with norby walters three times
three times i saved his life once from
corki vestola once from carmine persiglo
and once from my father because he was
using our name never paid us any money
he never got shook down he used us for
30 years and that's the reason he was in
trouble in the stage delication okay i
saved his life when my father came home
from prison and wanted to hurt him i can
say that now because my father's gone i
think i've said it before that's number
one so when this situation came up with
norby walters and i was subpoenaed
number one first they subpoenaed my
father and they subpoenaed my younger
brother and what i told them i said look
i'll tell you the truth about norby okay
when i get put on the stand let my
father and brother alone they did and
when i got on the stand you could look
at the testimony it's public record what
it said on the stand is i don't know who
norby is shaking down i've been in
prison i don't know i gave him 275 000
to be involved in this deal i got
involved because i wanted to meet
athletes for my gambling situation
that's exactly what i told him yeah
nobody got convicted and you know what
he had 25 people testify against about
the actual facts that happened in the
case so if you want to talk facts don't
just blow it off talk facts get the damn
testimony look at the trial don't be
like written house like everybody had
him convicted until the evidence comes
out in the trial and the poor kid got
got you know persecuted for no reason i
said talk facts that's number one as far
as number two what i did on the street
you have a knowledge of sammy don't
claim to know everything about everybody
else's business what i did with persico
or my father or anybody else who i
killed or didn't kill you have no
knowledge of so trust stop trying to
make people think you know everything
about everything because you don't
all right
let me finish i did not interrupt you i
did not interrupt you oh my god yeah
that's no more number two i'm telling
you this right now you can knock my
faith like you've been doing in almost
every interview that you keep going back
stop
you brought it up about the prayer
what's the matter you can't have a
response only you can have a response
anymore
no when you bring something up you're
entitled to a response yeah yeah you
said it nine times already well you said
it again you said it again i said you
brought it up for me for no reason when
you have somebody die in your house
there's a reason to play for him pray
for him every day he's already in heaven
you don't
i said to you know you stop your bs take
the text and put it up on the screen if
you want to be a big shot put it up on
the screen exactly what i said let me
ask you a second
i want to say something how did you get
that break
how did they go from ten years to three
[ __ ] years in prison first of all
three years old excuse me don't lie i
did eight years on the ten eight years
stop with your bs 3.4 i did eight years
it's a matter of record look up the bop
records stop what you did
stop putting your baloney you did 40
months years 29 months and seven days in
solitary because i wouldn't cooperate so
stop the baloney stop trying to cover
your own stealth by putting the blame
elsewhere sammy stop i don't do that to
you and you don't need to do that to me
what i did is a matter of public record
the same as you
and i don't care who looks at it yeah it
is a more a matter of public record and
i don't care
that you went and cooperated against
navi waltz and you want to say you went
there and saved him i just i didn't say
that
no you saved him three [ __ ] times
what the heck do you know about
do you have any idea what you're talking
about no yeah i know do you you went
exactly what i'm talking about you went
to testify in the case exactly what did
you do go to help them did you hear what
i just said i'm not going to notice that
i was subpoenaed and i told the truth
subpoenaed where were gangsters it's
peter don't be nothing
you don't go sammy you tell him i refuse
to answer let me see
oh you don't go who the hell are you
what do you mean you don't go you went
how many times i'm what i'm talking
about i cooperated i never went before
sammy i never sat with the government
before
why did you have to
only when i cooperated only when you had
yeah of course
why else would you sit down
sammy
you can paint this any color that you
want here's the facts i testified in the
norbie walters case go look up your damn
youtubes i said it 20 times okay
and all i ever said and i'll take this
to my grave and you can do all your
[ __ ] research that you want nobody
went to prison because of anything i
ever said i made sure that can you say
the same
are you right i know exactly what i'm
talking about because i lived it not you
you can pretend to live it you can
pretend to know everything but that's
all i thought i think you lost your
[ __ ] mind so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]